mariupol february the 27th three days
after russia's war on ukraine has begun
an air evacuation is underway
taking injured ukrainians to safety
the pictures were filmed by paramedic
yulia payevska with a small camera on
her forehead she would continue filming
in the beleaguered city until her
capture by the russians
julia is a star athlete in ukraine as
well as a paramedic she'd been given the
headcam to film for a documentary about
the invictus games
instead she captured intimate and moving
testimony of life inside the besieged
city of mariopol as the russian assault
takes hold
paramedics struggle to keep up with more
and more casualties
in the most harrowing moments julia
films as a brother and sister arrive
injured from a shooting at a checkpoint
their parents are already dead
where does it hurt sunshine she asks the
girl she reassures the child while
others try to resuscitate her brother in
vain
[Music]
i hate that she says crying her face to
the wall
[Music]
in the darkness outside she tells a
colleague the boy has gone
maybe the girl will survive
of course she says they are prisoners of
war
the russians have not been merciful in
their assault on mario pole unsparing in
their utter destruction of the city in
its wake they have rounded up and taken
away many ukrainians
among them yulia pyesca seized after
these pictures were taken
the last footage she films with her
camera
two weeks of war in besieged mario pole
she says
soon afterwards she and her friend were
abducted by the russians their
whereabouts are unknown
but not before she was able to smuggle
out her footage
a moving and sometimes harrowing record
of the courage of paramedics on the
front line saving lives in their
devastated city dominic waghorn sky news
hakeef